I knew where she went to hang out after
she had dumped me right and so I go to
like IO West you're gonna win her back
weren't you so I just went there
to like sit there and let her see that I
was hurt oh man oh Jesus
[Music]
welcome to careful boys we are very
careful boys oh [__] today
what is a cringe moment that you would
like to have back
oh damn wait cringe moment as in
something cringe happened to us or we
did something cringy [__] that I said
younger yeah oh yeah or yours completely
confident that you know what the [__]
you were talking about which what'd you
do I remember I just had this recent
flashback when I was flying on my plane
on the plane right and then I had this
cringe moment when I was like
[__] like 12 or 13 and I learned about
the whole free love movement in the 60s
right and then I was talking to a room
full of Boomers well at the time
um they were probably what in their 40s
or something like that and I was just
like man the world just needs to be like
the 60s again where people are just
giving free love to each other and
they're like that was about sex and I
was like huh I literally thought people
were just like more loving like hugs
free hugs free yeah
and my cousins were all just cool like
they were dying laughing because they
didn't know that it was just about like
just [__] no strings attached orgies
like I didn't know any of that I was so
embarrassed I was like that's not that
embarrassing
them
like how the world should be you know
what I mean
he's like I just think people need to
love each other more so but really what
he was saying is like people need to
finger bang each other a little bit more
that's Joe baby right and I'm like the
world is a better place back then and
I'm like I wasn't even born back then
like what the [__] am I saying to a
bunch of people that are actually living
that that that lived in the era or
whatever you know also at the table a
little bit
I went through a breakup right this is
like probably the worst break I've ever
went through because I was like I
thought I was like deeply in love with
this chick on stuff right and so we used
to do improv together and all that kind
of stuff and all the comedy stuff and I
knew where she went to hang out after
she had dumped me right and so I go to
like IO West at the time because I knew
she'd be there that night you're gonna
win her back weren't you nah this is
worse oh [__] I just because like I've
been with her for like two years or
whatever
so I just went there
to like sit there and let her see that I
was hurt oh man oh Jesus could you write
poetry
oh yeah
you went to just be a spectator do you
remember what you ordered did you order
anything did you get like a drink it's
all she's got a [__] virgin margarita
buffalo buffalo wings the bar area in
the lobby that thing is that bones Wings
you got my bones yeah just where all the
like you know where like there's interns
working right yeah and then there's like
the bar and then everyone's getting
pbr's yeah I'm like in the opposite
corner in one of the stools oh yeah
staring at this [__] [__] across the
room right and like so she's like
chopping it up with like whatever improv
dudes like every [__] improv do with
the messenger bag is around her right oh
man and then I'm just there like [__]
[__] hurt
sat there hurt
awful every time I think about it I
shudder what do you think at your mind
at that stage what was like the desired
outcome I didn't I just thought that I
know
I like this vulnerability but it's
hilarious heartbreak makes you do crazy
[__] [__] I was in a Vortex of like
[__] pain right I was just like this
is my chick right I was like I'm gonna
marry this [__] yeah
and then yeah she dumps me and then like
I was like she doesn't know I'm hurt
what if she doesn't know what did she
say to you when she dumped you do you
think that has something to do with it
like you should never [__] even look
at me again
and then he's like you know what I'm
gonna do look at him you're at the other
end of the bar in the stairs no
um no it was just like you know hey I'm
you know I don't remember honestly it
was it was such a [__] weird moment
but yes she dumps me she's like Hey
we're done and I'm like whoa it's crazy
like I lived with her and all this stuff
like we moved to LA together and like
whoa It's that one yeah that was a lot
there's a lot of life things a lot of
life things we had I mean she had me and
her done improv together in San Diego
moved to LA together like it was like a
whole we're like [__] like
intertwined and stuff and so
yeah I was just so hurt that I wanted
her to see that I was hurt because I
thought that she didn't know that I was
hurt and that if she saw me she would
know that because we always had a good
relationship like that and I thought oh
and then she'll know and then she'll be
good like the almost [__] cringy
early 20s [__] you could ever do because
in your mind you were thinking oh she'll
realize it goes you know what I do love
him exactly and what happened after she
saw you at the bar so she makes eye
contact with you and she's like honestly
I'll never forget it burned into my
[__] corneas she was just kind of
like this
oh why yeah like what the [__] are you
doing it's funny too because that place
is not very big he's not that far away
he like hit her with a spitball yeah
she's like orbs like the way thankfully
it wasn't like 5 15 and there's just me
and her and like four people there happy
hour two for one it was at least crowded
but my God I'm the tallest guy in the
room
[Laughter]
see her she her she can see me from
a cringy
like you guys were gonna chat and then
she's gonna realize well if I can
if I can get a little cocky for a second
yeah baby please do that [__] what I
thought was gonna happen is what ended
up happening three months later
who got the last laugh systematic
Revenge
is what I deployed to then that's kind
of your mood that's a Steve Green brand
that is my it's my Flex what I do
I mean look look at the chains bro the
reviews are red no so I ended up I
started going out with this like chick
who was like a model
and then my ex was like what the [__]
like oh [__] he's not hung up on me
still because I was hung up on her for a
while and she knew and she comes she
loves it she kind of like that but like
in that moment when she's going like
that to me
she didn't love it right but then once I
like was starting to just rebuild myself
and do better dude yeah do better right
then she was all like jealous as [__]
about it and she was like oh yeah you
moved on pretty quick wow she's really
she's really pretty and all this funny
you moved on pretty quick she was Ella
yeah was she going on any dates that you
were aware of I'm sure but no one that
not with this chick
so then yeah I was then but then this
chick with this new chick wouldn't like
do blowies and so I was kind of like nah
cool with that
that is the biggest struggle a guy could
ever have
what if she's like an oral model too
yeah and she's like a teeth mom and
she's so pretty you only have to see
that smile you know she's she's that
pretty you just want to see that mouth
stuff
filled up
to the brim
oh
you guys are gonna end my career it's
just funny you imagine you acting like
this because it's so not your character
you're such a sweet sweet boy like you
just would sock dudes like this hey I'm
gonna say something that's like for real
honestly this is the best therapy you
guys make me laugh so [__]
and you never know if it's real or not
let's just go home just yeah it's up to
your imagination
so that leads to but this leads into my
next cringiest moment so my ex is like
gunning hard at me showing up through my
door in French made costumes and [__]
not kidding whoa like offering like
every amount an angle of blow sex you
could ever imagine
seriously yeah dude seriously swear to
God in my life I know you didn't get to
do anal but check it out here's the
proposition this roller coaster ride so
then huh
80 Steve at it again yeah so then once I
have the ex back
she's like you need to tell the new
chick to know no more go away no more
right you need to tell
the new chick the model chick yeah
and so then I I had she had she made me
write this email that was like [__] up
oh this is Classic this is classic I've
seen this scenario happened multiple
times where one girl tells the guy you
need to tell her and then the email
comes it depends what you know how your
age this is weird this stuff is cheap he
knows this isn't mysterious this is just
cringy no your face is like but it's
just weird that he did these things
like BJ's yes it's just like if we're
gonna proceed you gotta like let the
noon you gotta let her go or whatever
yeah and then yeah I I wrote like this
[__] thing I was like it's all fake
it wasn't real and all [__]
today's video is brought to you by
Sunday
Springtime is finally here and look
everything's blooming everything's nice
if only there was something that can
help me with lawn care because you know
it gets super expensive when I have to
pay somebody and I enjoy doing my own
thing but at the same time when I go to
these big old stores with so many
different choices I don't know what to
do and that's where Sunday comes in
Sunday is everything you need to get the
long that you've been dreaming about
this spring go to getsunday.com off the
Record and enter your address to get a
customized plan created for your lawn no
trips to the store or hauling heavy bags
since they ship straight to your home
all you need is a hose to apply Sunday
it's pretty easy and you can fertilize
your lawn in less time than it takes to
watch our favorite TV show and they only
use ingredients that you can feel good
about no harsh chemicals no long waiting
periods or trying to keep your kids and
pets off the lawn and you're back to
enjoying your yard how wonderful very
nice Sunday is easy and affordable some
lawn care services cost more than
fifteen hundred dollars a year and
that's not my style but Sunday's full
season plan star starts just at a
hundred and nine dollars and Sunday is
offering our listeners 20 Off full
season plans start at just a hundred and
nine dollars and you can get 20 off when
you go to getsunday.com off the Record
at checkout that's 20 off your custom
plan at getsunday.com off the Record you
want to run out you got an email
do I have the email you should just read
it oh my God I know you got it
do you want the views sell yourself to
the devil baby I want to say that's
against it again no I don't know I don't
know I don't know if yeah I I trust me
it's cringy enough you don't have to
read we'll pay you for it yeah but yeah
check our patreon patreon yeah and how
did she respond to that email I hadn't
heard from her ever since oh no do you
feel like ever apologizing oh that is
the one person where I'd be like yo I'm
so sorry I was a [__] mess and you
didn't give BJs
sorry not sorry I mean you could have
made my choice real easy
holy crap remember Kazumi said that
there are some girls that are so hot
they don't have to give head
oh is that a thing you know what there
you know what I call them single okay
true
the conversation is a good code because
on the flip side you do male you say a
guy who's like oh I don't eat puss dude
like DJ Khaled I'm like I don't be like
DJ Kelly yeah
yeah like [__] Andrew Tate right he
sees he says it too does he not eat plus
he just says randomly he's single he's
not he's not wifed up dude see prove her
Point Andrew Tate he says he doesn't
need push guess what I don't know
anything about him I'm so glad Anthony
wasn't here so I could share all this
don't just sees judgment yeah he'd be
mad at you he'd be judging me yeah yeah
yeah because he if we ask Anthony that's
a major story man I have one that's not
really like cringy like I think about it
a lot and I just like feel really bad
about it like I feel terrible to this
day it was uh something I used to train
with well I still train with him he's
still a good friend but like I blew out
his knee
and it's like I think about it all the
time like when I'm showering way to
Humble brag no no but it was like it was
like such a dick move like what kind of
move was it that it was like it was
something kick them in The Shins no no
it's like in Jiu Jitsu like if someone
takes your back right or they're doing a
little backpack and they cross their
feet in front and then you cross your
feet on top of it oh and and then oh no
yeah and this is like at a time when I
was like really young I was like [__]
just trying to compete and like I was
like yeah bro like let's go get it
and I [__] I like I popped his knee
bro and it's like oh no and he's still
like had he he like jokes about it with
me and like ribs me about it but I'm
like bro like I feel
so [__] bad that I ever did that
because he still has issues like a
little bit he's like any he downplays it
but I'm sure it's probably way worse but
it's like I'll be in the shower like
dude this is what it gets me like I'll
just be shower right after and I'll just
think about it and I'll be like oh like
I'll taste dude I'll pace around I'll
get hot like my Palms are getting sweaty
thinking about it and anytime you bring
her you're thinking about popping a
dude's knee or something else when I
drove mine I'm just wondering
when he was straddling behind him yeah
all the blood rushes to my crotch and
then like I think about his knee dude I
do that too in the shower I just [__]
reminisce about all the cringy [__]
sometimes it just flashes in sometimes
I'm like oh that's When You're
vulnerable wouldn't you just chilling
I got another one this is more like
there was in high school that my friends
were trying to set me up with and like
we were like talking I was like oh she's
cute hook up whatever like hang out and
then the girl that was the mutual friend
was like hey I got an idea and we're
like Junior like you know like
sophomores or something like that she
was like hey come to the house or watch
scary movies right and then she'll be
you know like she don't wanna like oh my
God classic yeah I need a man yeah yeah
I'm scared so and I was like oh dude I
got that [__] easy your boy doesn't
really like scary oh bro
oh that's a good one
the original gory stuff scary stuff I
don't really have that much of a problem
but like gory stuff I can't do it bro if
you don't want to play a game I'm not
down to play a game it was like saw four
and [__] so you know by the time they
hit saw four it was like they were top
factor and I'm like bro this guy was
like hooked up yeah anyway so we started
watching the movie and like I couldn't
bro I couldn't I was like nah I'm good
bro oh I left
I left you completely come on man did
you say why did you say why nope I was
like I don't want to watch this movie I
was honest I don't want to watch this
[__] movie bro I'm out of here
and I went home I don't regret it at all
what'd you do when you went home you
played Zelda I was like you know what's
funny I at the time I was like I'm in
the rain like I'm totally in the right
it wasn't a couple like years later
where I was like that was the biggest
[__]
I'm going home yeah yeah so I think and
I recently thought about this and I was
like damn that is really embarrassing
let's do a song Marathon ah dude [__]
come on let's do it man no I'm not gonna
watch that movie dude I don't want to
watch that movie either I'm not into it
dude it makes me suck well if I do a
scary movie you're not gonna watch it
I'll watch it if you're in it
while he's doing this the whole time I'm
gonna be in saw 15. I honestly just
think I'm too [__] stupid to watch
stuff like that because I know it's
totally [__] and like they're using
fake meat and all this stuff yeah but I
still fall for it immediately and it's
still PTSD in my brain it sucked in yeah
yeah yeah it's funny yeah fake meat yeah
what is this fake chicken burger
seed oils and [__]
Beyond blood scares the [__] you know
there's like 50 people behind the camera
but it feels so intimate and small yeah
exactly I know they got candy [__]
eyeballs and [__] but I'm like oh my God
that's a reliable and [__] immediately
it's a great bro production blood I see
the titles and I'm like it's a movie and
then I'm sucked in right after that
that's good man can't do it no I'm out I
like that so it's just me and Steve yeah
Steve yeah what about you guys I can't
think of a like memorable cringy moment
though like
it's cringy you know as what we said
yeah because like my stuff is just like
high school [__] it's like you do dumb
[__] you know like you talk to girls get
rejected whatever it's like okay but is
that really cringy though yeah I had
like when I was in sixth grade uh like
we had the you know the computers were
just hitting like all the classrooms all
this stuff so everyone had like their
user ID and password
and I remember my boy was like oh yo
made this your password so he tells me
this I was like all right yeah
funny word
one day I get locked out of the system
and it's like reset your password had to
go tell the teacher blah blah they're
like what's your password
and I'm like my password is dildo
I'm in sixth grade
I had no idea what a dildo no clue
because my boy was just like to go make
a dildo
yeah like literally that was like I had
no [__] clue no clue because it
sounds funny yeah it just sounded I was
like dude it's funny and I was just I
just like yeah nothing like I said uh
like you know cheese yeah you know like
I was like yeah it's a dildo
and he was just like what is it I'll
never forget I'll never forget Mr Perry
my computer teacher I was like
dildo and then I said it louder because
like I thought he didn't hear them
he went you know sometimes people say
things and they don't know and they
don't know what they mean yeah this is
one of those moments all he knew he knew
that I didn't know because he had no
embarrassment nobody pulling out of the
table he's like
we're like yeah big glasses braces and
I'm like my password is dildo and
they're ripped for his pleasure
he's like he's like he's like he's like
what's your email you're like anal beads
out of my ass
and so what I thought was more funny was
that the fact that he didn't have the
balls to tell me what it was like just
be like hey just so you know he probably
doesn't want to be the one to tell you
like how do you explain that to us no no
so all he did was
because I couldn't can't look it up at
school because it's blocked right he's
like go out because he asked me why did
I do that and I was like oh my friend
told me yeah and then he goes go ask
your friend what that is what which I
thought was a smooth wave yeah that's
fair because then he knows like oh my
friend duped me and he doesn't get in
trouble talking about the stupid [__]
with me because I was a kid yeah that's
nice of him my friend told me yeah I was
like exactly
that's a double-sided never forget but
that's just like kid [__] growing up
like you're just an innocent idiot kid I
mean it is funny just say it cold yeah
just cold I was just like get dildo
there's one that like everyone always
makes fun of me about and it is pretty
cringy but um when I was on so you think
you could dance season one 2005. uh I
you have to go through this Gauntlet of
different classes from different
instructors that uh they make you do all
different styles you could do Ballroom
you could do contemporary hip-hop and
then it's kind of the object of the show
back then was to like fish out of water
thing to watch you like suffer in these
different styles you don't do and then
when I had to do the Contemporary one
which is sort of like ballet-ish at
least to me at the time
um the teacher was like all right I'm
just gonna put on the song and I just
want you to Freestyle in your own style
and she put on this slow like emotional
thing and then so I just started I
started breaking like doing what I do
but then trying to flow it and make get
all like beautiful and I was like really
like feeling it and [__] and then huh
that you know everyone got all like
emotional and [__] and then at the end
of the thing this is all like it made
the cut too on TV and then she's like
she uh she comes over and just like hugs
me and I was like in the moment and I
just remember like I [__] never want
to watch this clip because it's so
embarrassing but like I I like looked at
her or something and I was like out of
breath and I'm like
I've never danced like that to me
literally
wait was it Mia Michaels who was it it
wasn't me and Michael yeah that's
hilarious and she like loved it and she
was like kind of her tense like I never
danced like this is like the number one
contemporary choreographer she's won 19
Emmys in a row yeah and then she's like
I never danced like that before she was
like so like into it and it made me like
it made my head like blow up and it was
in the moment if I did hey man you were
vulnerable baby yeah it was but then I
sound so gay when I said that
but like you're an artist
what you thought was that real though
was that real what you felt I can't
believe I just inspired the world
I mean I'm glad I didn't do you know how
many break dances are now in their
basement with cardboard boxes trying to
do like arabesques it's on did you mean
that when you said that at the time yeah
because I really never have but I didn't
I didn't know that I sounded like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah you discovered a new
side of you I thought still sounded cool
and I bet the music that they added
wasn't flattering at all either I mean
it's it's like there's like it actually
is like okay but like it's just but your
boys oh dude all my friends but you're
like I was on TV and you're not to this
day even if we're like eating and
someone gets a sandwich you're like I've
never tasted cheese
like it's like a [__] thing I'm like
that's a good one
every time that's another one of this
Arsenal dude
laughs
foreign